thanit offshore wind farm was the
largest in the world when it was
commissioned it will be dwarfed in a
decade under government plans to
quadruple power capacity at sea
is that maintenance it's one of the crew
vessels yes investing in wind makes
sense for breezy britain but even the
industry thinks delivering is a
challenge it's taking at the moment up
to 10 years to get a project from the
drawing board into operation and part of
that half of that time is consense
the government today have said they want
to get that down to a year that's a real
acceleration
this field produces 300 megawatts of
power hitting the 50 gigawatt target
will need 150 times more
the government wants there to be enough
of these to power every home in the
country by 2030 and on days like today
wind is an abundant commodity but to
underwrite this bet on renewables we'll
still need fossil fuels there'll be new
north sea oil and gas licenses and a
massive investment in nuclear power and
none of this will bring down bills in
the short term
tell me what you want me to do harriet
okay come on so we've currently got one
pump in service
the prime minister was at the new
hinckley point nuclear reactor to
emphasize his faith in a still
contentious technology promising to
approve the equivalent of eight more in
as many years though not how to pay for
them
this is about tackling some of the uh
the mistakes of of the past and making
sure that we are set well for the future
and we're no longer subject to uh we'll
never again subject to the the vagaries
of the uh global oil or gas price we
can't be subject to blackmail
as it were from
people such as vladimir putin
onshore wind is the fastest cheapest
route to renewable energy but new
developments will remain blocked with
few exceptions following pressure from
conservative mps
this is where the pump is in here
the best way for consumers to cut bills
in emissions is to cut consumption with
new technology like air source heat
pumps
yeah no got no gas bills to worry about
and i believe they've gone a lot more up
a lot so i know that
so yeah i'm saving up for me all the
days now
there was no new money for this or
improving insulation in britain's aging
housing stock
it's all about electrification so
whether it's from nuclear or offshore
wind or onshore wind or solar panels
we've got to electrify society it's the
way we escape the way we make this the
last fossil fuel crisis the uk has to
suffer
this strategy was only planned after the
invasion of ukraine exposed european
reliance on russian gas a short-term
response to changing political weather
now has to stand the test of time paul
kelso sky news in kent